-We're about to play
a game of "Phone Booth,"
and we have some very specia
guests here to play it.
From AMC's "The Walking Dead,"
please welcome Norman Reedus
[ Cheers and applause ]
And Norman's opponent,
you can see her
in the new YouTube series,
"Justin Bieber: Seasons,"
give it up for Hailey Bieber
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for playing. The rules
of this game are very simple
I'll be asking you both
trivia questions.
If you get a question wrong, a
stranger from our mystery benc
gets shoved into
your phone booth.
[ Laughter ]
The first question
is for Hailey.
[ Telephone ringing ]
-Hello.
-Hey, what's up? It's Jimmy.
-Hey. How are you?
-How you doing?
-Good.
-Cool.
Hailey?
-Yes.
-Name three actors
who played James Bond.
-Daniel Craig.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
-Pierce Brosnan?
-That's correct.
-And --
Oh, man.
[ Slide whistle ]
Daniel Craig.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, I'm sorry,
Daniel Craig is only one person.
Hailey, you lost, which mean
joining your booth,
from the world-famous
Harlem Globetrotters,
currently playing in the 202
"Pushing the Limits World Tour,"
give it up for Jet Rivers!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, come on, dude.
You know what's --
Oh! Come on, now.
[ Laughing ] Oh!
Come on, bud.
Good to see you, buddy.
You know Hailey?
♪♪♪♪
-I'm gonna bring this
in here with you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Next question --
The next question is for Norman.
[ Telephone ringing ]
-Hello?
-How you doing, bud?
-Hey.
-Hey, I have a question for you.
What brass instrument
was once known as the sackbut?
-The what?
-The sackbut.
♪♪♪♪
The sackbut.
-Saxophone?
-That is incorrect.
I'm so sorry.
It was the trombone
is the correct answer.
-That makes no sense.
-Joining Norman's booth,
they've got one thing
on the brain, and it is brains
it's "The Walking Dead" zombies.
Oh, my --
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's hilarious.
-Oh, my goodness. Oh!
-[ Yelling ]
-Oh, my -- Oh, they're coming.
Oh, my gosh. Be careful!
Oh. It's getting cramped.
-That's a regular day for you.
-It's getting cramped in there
Be sure --
Make sure you close the door
Absolutely right.
Alright.
-Hi, guys.
-[ Growls ]
-Our next question
is for Hailey.
[ Telephone ringing ]
-Hello?
-Hey, it's Jimbo.
-Hey.
-Hailey, Justin Bieber has had
several Billboard Hot 100
#1 hit songs.
-Mm-hmm.
-Name three of them.
-"Sorry."
-Uh-huh.
-"What Do You Mean?"
-Yes.
-"Baby."
-No.
-"Sorry," "What Do You Mean?
and --
and "Where Are U Now."
-No.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer, foghorn ]
-They're cheating. You cheated
-The answers were, "Sorry,
"Love Yourself,"
"What Do You Mean?"
"I'm the One," or "Despacito."
-Right -- Oh, right!
-She said that.
-I forgot that!
-Joining Hailey's booth,
from American polka band
Don't Polka the Bear,
it's accordionist Derek Franz!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah!
[ Accordion playing ]
[ Accordion plays off-key
-Hey! Hello!
-Hi.
Welcome.
[ Accordion plays ]
-Our next question
is for Norman.
[ Telephone ringing ]
-[ Grunts ]
-That doesn't sound like Norman.
-[ Growling, panting ]
-Alright, Norman?
Norman, you got this one.
How many letters are in the name
Benedict Cumberbatch?
-Oh, man.
-He can't count.
[ Growling ]
-[ Groaning ]
-Don't -- No hints.
-19.
19?
-That is correct!
The answer is 19!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Aw, yeah.
-Joining Hailey's --
Joining Hailey's booth,
from Ontario, Canada,
it's the world's oldest
Justin Bieber impersonator
[ Laughter ]
-Yummy, yummy, yummy.
-Yummy, yummy, that's right.
Just go --
Justin --
-That one?
-Justin, this way.
Yep. There you go.
[ Laughter ]
Yummy, yummy, yummy.
[ Accordion playing off-key
That's right.
Alright, very good.
Yummy, yummy, yummy, very good
[ Laughter ]
-How do I answer the phone
-Alright, here we go. This i
the final call right here,
as we know by this sound effect.
[ Disconnected phone beeping ]
Thank you.
Hailey? Hailey?
-Yes?
[ Telephone ringing ]
Hey, Jimmy.
-Hey, what's up?
How did you know --
How did you know it was me
-I just took a wild guess.
[ Laughter ]
-Hailey, which one
of these balls weigh the most --
football, basketball,
or soccer ball?
♪♪♪♪
-Basketball.
-Is that your final answer
-That's my final answer.
-You are correct!
[ Ding! ]
-Because I had it in here!
-Come on.
-The winner of this question
gets to shove everyone els
from the mystery bench
into their opponent's booth.
You are the winner.
Let's bring out the bench,
First, You know her.
You love her.
She stars in Bravo's hit
reality show, "Below Deck,
my favorite, give it up fo
everyone's favorite chief stew
Kate Chastain!
-Hi. Nice to see you.
-Come on, pal. I love you.
-Thanks. I go over here?
-Yeah, go on in.
Say hi to Norman. Norman's -
-Come on in.
-Hey!
-Some zombies.
-Guys, you can head over there
if you want.
Next, the Instagram sensatio
who needs no introduction,
it's Dude with Sign.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Am I getting out?
-You can get in there, too
And finally,
from Syracuse University,
Otto the Orange, everyone!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Nice to see you, Otto.
Get on in there.
That's perfect right there
Our thanks to Norman Reedus,
Hailey Bieber,
Kate Chastain, Jet Rivers,
the Harlem Globetrotters,
Dude with Sign,
and Syracuse University!
More "Tonight Show"
after the break!
Stick around!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Aah!
-[ Speaking indistinctly ]
♪♪♪♪